this video is sponsored by surf shark
let's get started raleigh
what you can't leave it there oh my
i am back for my short break away and i
am ready to tackle the rest of this one
piece story
fully energized to complete my quest to
catch up with the rest of the world
in this sprawling high seas adventure
spanning almost 1 000 chapters
as of writing this video but as of my
last video part 12's completion i have
covered 597 chapters of this japanese
nautical epic as well as the first major
section of this story and with that now
in the books i thought this week in
addition to covering the reuniting of
the straw hat crew during their return
to save audi i thought it would be fun
to also reveal my top five favorite arcs
of the story
and my personal ranking of all the straw
hat pirates
i think i've got a decent enough grasp
of this merry band of misfits in order
to effectively rank them accordingly
right now and that's not even to mention
my favorite arcs also
but before all that let me say i am back
but please for the love of god like and
share this video because the algorithm
probably hates me right now but
all of that aside i am ready to tackle
the rest of this incredible story
beginning with my first impressions of
thoughts on and review for
the heartwarming the tense and the funny
return
[Music]
oh by the way i see your comments oh
mark cries at everything he's overly
emotional he needs to
burn up first off rude but moreover i
don't actually cry that much
i meant it when i said that before
reading one piece i never cried while
reading before
now do i cry while watching films and tv
shows yes
like a fountain but that's besides the
point and what's more is
i haven't just been resting during this
vacation from the world of one piece
i've been training i've been watching
the notebook marley and me
and your name on loop for the past two
weeks straight and i can now proudly
declare that not only do i not cry
but i am also an emotionless vacuum void
of even the most fundamental
basic level of humanity so with my
newfound grit and determination
let's open the story and get back to
work
okay i didn't actually cry here but
after taking my time away from this
story after
having sung so much time into it
beforehand it was sort of nice seeing
the story kick off again
after what was in universe two years
worth of training and time spent apart
effectively this very short arc explores
the changes that crew have undergone
including emotional intellectual and in
many cases physical changes
with everyone in varying degrees
changing their appearances
they are after growing up considerably
in the last two years
and that is very much made evident
throughout this reintroduction of the
straw hats as they rendezvous at the
archipelago
so let's check it out two years later i
think my favorite thing about this
chapter is how it's framed and presented
the very last chapter i covered before
this long break away in my last video
saw the very last panel with luffy
placing his hat
on a rock symbolizing the beginning of
his training and his long break away
from his friends
and this chapter following the time skip
sees that very hat
on that rock now covered in snow
signifying the passage of time
and dedication luffy has had in his
training but and i am not sure how it's
presented in the anime
but in the manga this chapter takes
expressed interest in not showing
us the audience luffy's face pretty much
for the entire chapter
right up until the very end the straw
hat is back
and he's on his way to meet his friends
something i really like in this chapter
2 was the laid back and fun character
reintroductions we got with the rest of
the straw hat crew we see
sanji who now parts his hair on the
other side no that's growth
we see nami and not to mention usopp
who's gotten so much more buff
we see chopper robin rayleigh lots of
reintroductions that filled me with all
sorts of nostalgia
i wasn't expecting heading back into
this however the most interesting part
of this small collection of chapters
comes in the form
of this group of imposter straw hat
pirates every one of them pretending to
be a particular part of the crew
drawing attention to their presence in
the very area they were taken out last
time
on the very day the real straw hats are
planning to leave it's a little more on
the convenience side than i'm used to
with one piece
but i'll leave things slide because i'm
still enjoying it and we see moments
like this when the real luffy engages
with the fake luffy
[Music]
that is a baller move if ever i did see
one
however the real reason this crew is
important is primarily down to them
being the catalyst for the real conflict
of the ark you see the reason i called
this convenient earlier is largely down
to the fact that had they not been at
that archipelago that particular day
exactly two years from when luffy sent
that message
the real straw hats wouldn't have had
any conflict really at all that day
when they were leaving but needless to
say they do
and when the navy catch up with the
pirates regrouping at this archipelago a
very familiar scene begins forming
the pacifistas arrive but this time
things are different
that's right zoro's got one eye now well
that sucks for him
but seriously it's really cool to see
the progression all of these guys have
gone through
communicating to us visually the stark
difference between them then
and then now oh also there's this really
bad guy
in the ranks of the fake straw hats that
led them to be ultimately disbanded and
taken over
who looks like he'll be important later
considering how much focus he got on
during these chapters and
i mean just look at that character
design but moreover the best part about
this reintroduction to the series is the
humor and flavor the arcs set
up for us there's this tremendous sense
of anticipation and joy when the straw
hats are looking for each other at the
archipelago
and when they all do eventually arrive
at the thousand sunny after it's
finished being prepped by rayleigh for
deep sea adventures
luffy doesn't spend much time embracing
or hugging them but instead gets right
back to business
they have an adventure to go on and with
that they dive
into the deep below it's awesome and i
can't wait to see what's next
also shout out to duval who kept the
ship safe for like two years
what a guy but before i move on next
week to the rest of this epic story with
my review of fishman island
i thought with this being the natural
break in the story it would be the
perfect time for me to share with you
guys my top five
favorite arcs and my rankings of the
straw hat crew i shared my personal
rankings of the straw hat pirates a few
months ago on twitter so it'll be
interesting to see how much that list
has changed today and whether or not it
will change again by the time i finish
this story but
first things first time to list off
tnm's top five favorite arcs from one
piece's first half
even though it's not really a half it's
more like the first sixty percent
choosing your favorite arcs in a long
running series can be an excruciatingly
difficult enterprise
having to take into account your own
personal feelings on the matter while
also taking into consideration the
broader context and significance it
plays in the greater story a troubling
challenge
for sure if you're a scrub today i
present totally not mark's perfectly
balanced and clearly objective list
of the absolute best arcs in one piece
and if yours isn't on here that means
you're objectively wrong and i'm
absolutely calling your taste trash
this is a joke so what are we waiting
for let's kick things off with number
five
the skypia arch
funnily enough while i write this i get
the distinct impression that there will
be a large number of you that will take
specific issue with skype and making my
list of favorite arcs from this first
section of the series
and while i can't speak to how the anime
told the story specifically i can only
speak to my own experiences and i found
skype to not only be incredibly fun
but even after all has been said and
done it might actually be the most
ambitious standalone arc i've read of
one piece
while it does lean on material
established in jaya the skypie arc
even discounting the aspects from jaya
establishes so much and pays off
everything in a single story arc an
entirely new aesthetic for the world's
environments new technology
many new cultures with their own visible
social structures
as well as hints to powers that become
incredibly important the longer the
story pushes forward and perhaps the
most impressive aspect is that these
superlative world building attributes
inform the story being told and its
conclusion i described skypea as a
combination of dances with wolves
indiana jones and jack and the beanstalk
and to be honest i stand by that it's
got the magic of a fairy tale the
adventure to rival any of indiana jones
best and it has a sense of foreboding
that distinctly reminds me of the
frontier in north america juggling
literal magic
incredible fight scenes and complex
social dilemmas that create such a
specific flavor that it's unmistakably
specifically skypia this arc
i adored and it has an identity more
distinct than
any other on this list number four
arlong park
if you can't pay the cash then you're
out with the trash
if not for arlon park this entire
one-piece series i've created might not
have existed
something a lot of you might not be
aware of is that when i decided to
tackle this one piece story
i did so with only two videos planned
concretely the first covering romanced
onto parity and the second
covering the events of arlong park i had
said to myself and my friends at the
time that if the story had not captured
my own interest or my audiences at that
point i would have stopped there and
then
not having continued the story at all
but this arc
arlong park changed my perspective on
one piece
entirely transforming from a sort of
ordinary shonen adventure story to an
emotionally mature action drama dealing
with themes and personal dilemmas that
not
only served to hold my interest but as
many of you became aware of during this
video series
acted as the impetus for me to become
incredibly attached to these characters
in a way that i had not experienced with
stories
i had grown up with taking the primary
point of view character to be nami
we get tons of backstory and real life
struggle that not only build up an
incredibly tragic picture of nami's life
up until that point but also a
powerfully emotional interaction between
two spectacular characters
the likes of which i hadn't personally
been exposed to before arlen park hits
emotional highs that rival any of the
other arcs in my opinion
number three water 7.
i spent a shocking amount of time
deliberating which i'd include
on this list from the water 7 saga the
water 7 arc or any slop
and to be perfectly honest i was a much
bigger fan of water 7
than the latter now that's not to say
that i didn't enjoy or love andy's lobby
it was brilliant it just wasn't as good
as the other entries on this list for me
water 7 offered a ton
of variety comedy and stood as the
backdrop for the single most emotional
and compelling conversations in the
entire series that i've seen anyway to
this date usap and luffy's interactions
during this arc are still my
favorite examples of creative writing
and dialogue from the entire series
also offering my favorite fight scene 2
between them in addition to that i love
the way the city of water 7 looked the
picturesque landscapes and waterways
offered a lot in the way of world
building and that's not
even to mention the intriguing plot with
nico robin and the swerve at the very
end with sanji being one step ahead of
everybody at the train station
thinking back to my page turn onto that
reveal still makes me smile
i loved andy's lobby as a fantastic
climax to the story but water 7 really
did
have everything else that made that arc
as good as it was
it established characters relationships
subversions and it still had more
compelling action to boot
for me water 7 was on another level and
takes the number three spot
easily number two alabasta
similar to the last entry i spent a lot
of time deliberating whether or not
alabasta would take the top spot or this
one
and it's easy to see why the alabasta
arc is lengthy but not too long and it
is its very own
intricate self-contained story full of
new characters political structures
wonderful geography wildlife and
action but even taking all of that out
of the equation the alabasta arc does a
phenomenal job of interweaving emotion
and feeling into the narrative
through short but illuminating scenes
like that between the old man and luffy
and yuba
vivi's lamenting at her country falling
into ruin and even through all the major
characters providing the single best
send-off in the series
which felt so distinctly one piece it
hurt and that's not even to make mention
of my favorite warlord of the sea in
crocodile
while we would later meet and face off
against other warlords of the sea
some being even more formidable than
crocodile there's no denying the
charisma and
bond villainess type aura croc brought
to each and every single scene he
engaged within
offering a move set that posed
interesting challenges to the themes
fights and overall plot of the story
croc was
a near-perfect inclusion for this arc
and served it accordingly but one more
additional aspect that made alabasta
stand out amidst the rest
was how it incorporated and made use of
every single main character
like no other utilizing all the straw
hats and luffy in tandem creating a
sense that everyone was struggling to
the very end it's a spectacular
action-packed rich and emotional
rollercoaster that i literally
could not recommend more number one
marine ford
30 chapters in 30 chapters oda created a
climax that befitted not just a
four-part saga but created established
and delivered an incredible climax
equally cathartic and tragic in measure
for the entire series so far
to reiterate this wasn't just a great
climax for the saga
but a great climax for the series so far
that shouldn't be possible let alone in
30 chapters
recontextualizing relationships
established in the first chapter
during alabasta and thereafter this arc
takes all the best elements from all the
other arcs and smashes them together in
a war effort the likes of which i have
not seen yet committed to the page of a
manga the struggles are visceral the
tension is high
and the battles are nothing short of
brutal with violence the likes of which
we've not seen in the series and
consequences that will echo throughout
the pages of every subsequent volume
i'll read through into the future
marineford is the endgame of one piece a
story that shouldn't be possible to pull
off
but somehow it was and i was utterly
floored by it
and while acts like any lobby also
concern themselves with just a climax
like marine ford
unlike any lobby marine ford introduces
and is about
whitebeard and ace with the relationship
taking center stage
acting as its very own standalone story
in some measure all the while
introducing new characters reintroducing
old ones establishing set pieces and
that's not even to mention the
complicated action that
literally everyone is taking part in
this was the act that demonstrated so
perfectly why otis spending all that
time world building and establishing
characters over the course of the series
worked so well in his favor i have in
the past seen shows or other pieces of
media create a war setting
and while some are closer than others
none in my opinion even approached this
level of satisfaction and urgency marine
ford so effortlessly delivered
[Music]
[Applause]
i'd like to extend a special thank you
to surfsharkvpn for sponsoring today's
video we've never been more reliant on
the internet than we are today and this
reliance is rapidly increasing our
entertainment our finances and even some
of us have jobs that rely on a robust
online infrastructure as our online
presence is ever increasing we'd like to
think we're safe too
and so we need proper security surfshark
is a vpn service that protects your
information from unwanted individuals by
encrypting all the data that you send
through the internet but a great reason
to use a vpn is for content that might
be hidden behind certain region locks
like netflix does with surfshark you can
solve that problem by simply changing
your location not only is this good for
people who want to keep up with their
favorite shows but it's great for me
specifically because i want to watch one
piece on netflix when it's inexplicably
blocked in my country
this very moment surfsharkvpn has a
great deal going by following my link in
the description and using your promo
code tnm it not only gives you a
whopping
85 off but also three months of service
totally for free surfshark also offers a
30 day money back guarantee so there's
no risk in trying it out for yourself
now back to the video i figured out that
when you get wet
your body hardens so you can be
clobbered when you're a big stiff
i'm angry and i'm wet
[Music]
okay time to rank all nine of the straw
hats don't
hurt me ranking the straw hats was a
much more difficult task than choosing
my favorite arcs i found myself
flip-flopping between
so many of them but i had to make my
decisions at the end of the day
so here they are let it be known however
that before i dive in
just because certain straw hats are at
the bottom of my ranking list here
that doesn't mean i don't like them it
just means that i like them less than
the ones towards the top so
coming in at number nine
i like brooke i think he can be funny
and his backstory is one of the most
tragic if not the most tragic out of all
of the straw hats
and while this might be my lack of time
spent with the character talking
i found personally that if i removed all
of his crass gags about women's
underwear
and removed his skeleton puns while
there is definitely a character beneath
i didn't see as much
of that as i would have liked to outside
of thriller bark this could very easily
change in the future and i hope it does
from the little amount his character has
gotten to shine in the series so far
what i have seen i very much enjoyed
so hopefully the future offers much more
in the way of characterization for
brooke
time to jump to number eight
frankie this might have been the
toughest decision i made on the list to
say that i flipped back and forth
between
frankie and the next straw hat on this
list is nothing short of an
understatement however despite frankie's
relatively low ranking here i really do
love his character
of all the straw hats he might be one of
the most charismatic
i enjoy him because he's a big lovable
goofball but he also comes packed with
some great utility in fighting and ship
repairs
frankie offers the gang their ship to
continue their voyage and in a lot of
ways this very
ship saves them despite its very brief
stint with them so far however perhaps
the most impressive aspect of frankie's
character is that his introduction arc
wasn't at all about him really but
instead about another
robin but despite that this charismatic
robotic skimpy trunk wearing
thousand sunny repairing madman managed
to cement himself as part of the straw
hats in a way
so perfect i couldn't imagine the crew
without him but one character that has
risen in my estimation to a great extent
is coming next in my number
seven spot
chopper for the absolute longest time
chopper was at the very bottom
of my ranking list he was a character i
didn't really have that much interest
in and while i didn't dislike the
character he was for the longest time
the character that flirted with being
boring the most for me
not that he was boring but more so
because he never really had much to
contribute besides being scared and
doubtful of himself which are the
character traits of a much more
interesting character that's much higher
on this list
in short he didn't have anything really
that helped him stand out which is a
really strange thing to say about a
transforming deer
however once that was explored in drum
island the novelty that that sort of
devil fruit ability provides
left me saying okay what else do you
have to offer to this dynamic
and really he sort of fell into the
background with characters like nami
usop and luffy
taking center stage thereafter that is
until this happened
this sort of enhancement was exactly
what chopper needed in order to remain
competitive and to remain interesting in
combat in ways
only he can these sorts of techniques
much like the kaioken from dragon ball
are gambles
very much this is a dire situation move
where the host throws the dice
in what he identifies as a moment of
absolute desperation and once this
moment popped off in islam before the
little guy
i began looking at chopper more closely
which was great as he became a more
active character thereafter engaging in
the battle with moria on thriller park
in a very creative rich way employing
his knowledge of anatomy and medicine to
prove crucial in the closing moments of
the encounter
i hope to see more from him in the
future but that's enough about chopper
for now
let's look at the straw hat who took my
number six spot
sanji now that we're approaching the
middle of this list we will start seeing
straw hats that once occupied the top
spot more and more
sanji is the first such character that
occupied the rank of number one in my
estimation however as other characters
shone brighter he remained the same and
in some respects in my opinion became
less interested
very quickly right after we were
introduced to him in varite in the arc
immediately following that
sanji asserted himself as being one of
the key players in the dynamic of the
straw hats and he still very much
is today spanning from bharati all the
way through to any
lobby for 400 chapters sanji proved to
be the difference maker and a capable
fighter
whether that be in ireland park saving
luffy in alabasta as mr prince or in war
7 as he anticipates something no one
else did in waiting at the train station
but perhaps the most interesting part of
his character for me was his dynamic
when dealing with women from the very
beginning he placed women on a pedestal
treating them like royalties straddling
and pushing the line of chivalry and
while this proved to be challenging in a
lot of aspects throughout alabasta
onward this particular trait in sanji
was highlighted during ini's lobbied by
nami as a negative which
i was so excited for as it offered a
really refreshing change of pace from
the perverted character
that seemed to be so prevalent in shonen
and eastern comics in general from
alabasta through to eddie's lobby
sanji was my favorite character but
perhaps i had gotten the wrong
impression of him as when thriller back
rolled around and
even now in later acts like return to
shabbat he seems to be leaning into a
more
traditional perverted aspect of his
character that i personally found
incredibly boring compared to the
direction i thought they were going to
take with him
now if you like him more power to you i
still enjoy him from time to time too
but nowhere near what i did which
for me is a shame number five
zorro i get the distinct feeling that
this one might be very controversial
i'm sure that given the kind of
character zorro is he'd be at the top or
at least second from the top for many of
the people watching this video
and it's easy to see why he's strong
he's badass and he's incredibly loyal to
his friends
and while he bets a lot of the straw
hats lore on this list
i find him to be fairly middle of the
road when it comes to entertainment
in fact i still think sanji offers a
much more interesting dynamic than zorro
however there isn't anything about zorro
that i don't like so
that's why he beat sanji for me in this
instance but what stops him from being
higher on this list
like many of you would like him to be is
his formulaic use in the narrative
if you go back over the story from
zora's recruitment all the way to the
end of thriller bark's main story
all zorro did for the most part was
sleep drink
fight the second strongest guys and be
the quote cool guy in the group
which i didn't find particularly
interesting however
since then there's been a tremendous
effort on behalf of oda to draw
attention and highlight zorro's role as
the perfect first mate for luffy which
he demonstrated quite effectively
throughout the series
in moments like water 7 against kuma in
thriller bark and even in training with
hawkeye
these moments elevate him from what
would have been a lower position for me
to a middle position and i love him next
up
nami nami's a fantastic character
an all-rounder she's funny cool clever
and she offers a lot of variety in how
the story can be told
she's not the strongest but when it gets
down to the wires she often comes
through with a clutch play
either by pickpocketing something of
value or stealing something crucial
unlike luffy zorro and sanji she doesn't
have the option of brute forcing her way
out which is so interesting in his
shonen compared to everything else from
the moment she was introduced all the
way through alabasta
she was my favorite character and to be
honest would have remained as such had
the dynamic in the group
not changed so much with her character
now sort of finding herself as a person
to save rather than someone who does the
saving
or makes clutch plays anymore but who
knows maybe that will change the story
unravels
maybe she'll regain the number one spot
again but as of right now she's my
number four so
let's dive into the top three
[Music]
usopp now we are on the business end of
this list
these three characters change on a
chapter by chapter basis but all of them
offer tons in the way of creative
character moments and dialogue
entanglements
and while usopp is at number three here
he has on a number of occasions occupied
the top spot also
easily one of the best characters the
series has produced usof offers every
story he takes a leading role in
in valuable opportunities to utilize his
fear and bravery to create moments equal
parts tense and emotional in measure
whether it be through his interactions
with nami and arlon park his fight
alongside chopper against the baroque
works in alabasta
or his best friend soga king and that's
not even to make mention of the part he
played in the single greatest dialogue
exchange i've seen come out of water 7
and this series
usopp is amazing and i will fight anyone
who says otherwise
but as of right now there are two i find
more interesting
robin while characters like chopra usop
or sanji and zorros share a lot in
common with each other i was beginning
to get scared that no straw hat that
would be introduced in the future would
be able to feel like they had their own
identity
enter nico robin
the way with which this character
integrates herself into the story was
out of the straw hats the most
interesting to me not as a good guy like
sanji and not as a neutral force like
nami
but instead as one of the more
formidable antagonists presented to us
in the story at that time proving to be
equal parts calm and cool
while also being super intelligent and
quippy she also comes with my favorite
flashback sequence that illuminates so
much more about the wider world
and world government than i was
anticipating at the time of reading it i
love her dialogue i love her powers
i adore that her motivations still color
her decisions even to this day
hundreds of chapters after the first
time we met her and i love that the fact
that she's a girl doesn't play a role in
her character she could easily be a guy
and be just as interesting i love the
character and i cannot wait to see
what's to come for her in the future
now that i know she might have some
interesting info regarding dragon
but that leaves one straw hat and i
think you all know who that
is
luffy i didn't think i was going to like
luffy as much as i did throughout this
series
with him being the character we spend
the most time with by far in the entire
story and with him being introduced to
us in the very first chapter there's
been only one
single moment in the entire story where
i thought his character
didn't make sense that being on whiskey
peak when he tried to kill zoro but
aside from that
luffy has literally only gotten more
interesting to me over time chapter by
chapter in the different things he does
sometimes big sometimes small but always
informed by his character
as it paints and colors every piece of
dialogue he spouts
luffy is a perfect protagonist for this
story obviously he's exciting and
endearing which are fantastic traits to
have for a protagonist but what i think
makes him a terrific one
is how active he is as a character
within the story unlike a lot of other
characters he doesn't sit back and let
the plot just happen to him
luffy happens to the plot he's a
go-getter and for better or worse
goes out into the world and causes great
things to happen and
sometimes terrible things to happen but
always entertaining
with a backstory that gets drip fed to
us throughout the course of the entire
series
luffy isn't only interesting but comes
with far more depth that a character
like him might look to have on first
viewing with oda taking specific care
and establishing every aspect of him
fleshing him out and forcing us to see
him in a very visceral believable way
and in doing so he is now up there with
goku as some of my favorite characters
in all of fiction he's courageous he's
kind and he's ambitious beyond measure
he makes the impossible seem possible
he's monkey d luffy and he's the captain
and my favorite of the straw hat pirates
and thus concludes today's video
it feels so good to be back and i'm
really excited to get back into the
swing of things next week with fishman
island
but that'll do it for this video i've
been totally not mark
i'll see you all next week and thank you
so much for waiting
and thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you